Jean-Luc Picard is one of Star Trek's most
legendary captains, but the man has a long,
complicated history with the Enterprise and
its crew.
If you want the lowdown on his story, then
here’s Picard’s entire timeline explained.
Born in La Barre, France, young Jean-Luc Picard
had a troubled upbringing.
The first glimpse of his childhood comes in
the "Star Trek: The Next Generation" episode
titled "Family," where he visits his brother
Robert on Earth.
In this episode, we learn that Jean-Luc and
Robert helped their father take care of the
family's vineyards.
We also learn that the rest of Jean-Luc's
family are traditionalists.
They don't trust advanced technology like
replicators and certainly don't have a high
opinion of the vaunted Starfleet.
All the while, his brother is something of
a bully to him.
But we learn much more about the young Picard's
early life in Season 2 of "Star Trek: Picard."
Apparently, he had an especially close relationship
with his mother Yvette.
But Yvette suffered from severe mental illness,
and despite her husband Maurice's pleas, she
refused to seek help.
As a result, Maurice is often forced to lock
her in her room to prevent her from self-harm
during particularly difficult episodes.
This leads to one of the most life-altering
moments in Jean-Luc's life.
Amid one of his mother's episodes, she calls
out to Jean-Luc to let her out of her room.
When he does, it leads to his mother's suicide.
Picard carries the guilt of this incident
with him all of his life, only finally coming
to terms with it as an older man.
Moving past the tragedy, Jean-Luc's time on
the family vineyard continues to frustrate
him, as he has little interest in the family
business of winemaking.
It doesn't take long for Jean-Luc to figure
out that his path leads to the stars, and
the future Enterprise captain soon gains a
reputation as an overachiever, becoming a
sports champion as well as valedictorian of
his high school.
"Never sought president of the school, valedictorian,
athletic hero with your arms raised in victory?"
Against his father's wishes, Jean-Luc leaves
home for Starfleet Academy as soon as the
opportunity arises, though it takes him two
attempts before his application is accepted.
In Season 6's "Tapestry," we learn a little
bit more about what kind of man he is during
his Academy days.
Far from the steady, stoic, commanding leader,
Picard is a brash, fiery, cavalier sort, and
even something of a womanizer while at Starfleet
Academy.
It's there that he meets both Jack Crusher
and Beverly Howard, and they become close friends.
We also learn that he had something of an
unrequited crush on Academy mate Marta Batanides.
But we also witnessed an event just after
his exit from the Academy that leaves its
deepest mark on him.
While waiting for his first assignments, Picard
gets into a brawl with a group of Nausicaans
over a game of dom-jot.
Overmatched but refusing to back down, Picard
is stabbed through the heart, and while he
survives the injury, he's left with an artificial
organ in his heart's place.
We don't have many details about Picard's
Picard's post-Academy life before he got command
of his own ship.
We learn in the second season TNG episode
"The Measure of a Man" that he once served
aboard the USS Reliant, but more is known
about his time aboard the USS Stargazer.
There, Picard started as a bridge officer,
but he made his way up the ranks the old-fashioned
way — being the highest ranked officer left
alive in the middle of a battle.
Jean-Luc commanded the Stargazer for two decades,
until he and the surviving crew were forced
to abandon the vessel after a battle with
a Ferengi ship.
"Who are they?
Identify them."
"They're turning for a third pass at us, sir!
We can't take another hit, Captain!"
That final battle led to the "Picard Maneuver"
being coined for the unorthodox move Jean-Luc
made to destroy the enemy vessel.
More personally relevant to Picard was his
friendship with Jack Crusher aboard the Stargazer.
Jack was the late husband of Beverly Crusher
and father to Wesley, both of whom wind up
serving aboard the Enterprise.
It's Picard who, while commanding the Stargazer,
sent Jack Crusher on an away mission that
led to his death.
When we meet Picard in the Next Generation
series premiere, he's already taken command
of his famous ship.
His orders send him to Deneb IV:
"Beyond which lies the great, unexplored mass
of the galaxy."
On the way there, the Enterprise has its first
fateful meeting with the trickster, god-like
alien Q.
With a few short breaks here and there, Picard
remains in command of the Enterprise-D until
its destruction in 1994's Star Trek: Generations.
He and his stalwart crew get to explore quite
a bit of that "great, unexplored mass," and
along the way, they encounter aliens both
benevolent and hostile, including the fan-favorite Borg.
In the season two episode "Q-Who?," the deceitful
Q uses his powers to send the Enterprise deep
into unexplored parts of the galaxy where
they encounter the Borg for the first time.
The Borg act as a single collective mind and
rebuff all attempts at communication in favor
of seeking to overpower the Enterprise.
Although they're eventually returned to Federation
space, it's clear the crew hasn't seen the
last of the Borg.
"Since they're aware of your existence…"
"They will be coming."
The Borg re-emerge in the two-parter "The
Best of Both Worlds," when they kidnap Picard
and assimilate him into their collective.
Picard is eventually rescued, and it proves
the Borg's Achilles' heel as his connection
to the collective allows Data to command the
invaders to sleep.
But it's clear Picard is severely traumatized
by the experience.
This wouldn't be Picard's last encounter with
the Borg, however.
In "I, Borg," the Enterprise crew rescue a
Borg who's somehow capable of independent thought.
They meet him again in the two-part "Descent"
as the leader of a group of liberated Borg
resisting the control of Data's twin brother,
Lore.
And finally, Picard would be forced to confront
the Borg and his overwhelming need for vengeance
against them in 1996's Star Trek: First Contact,
when the aliens attempt to assimilate the
Federation by going back in time before the
Federation's founding.
One of the most interesting relationships
on Star Trek: The Next Generation is the kinship
that develops between Picard and the android
Data.
By the end of the series and the subsequent
films, it's clear Picard holds the android
close to his heart.
He sees Data as, at the very least, a close
friend.
However, at times their connection doesn't
seem all that different than that between
a father and a son.
Picard reveals part of his fascination with,
and admiration for, Data in the second season
episode "The Measure of a Man."
Data attempts to resign his commission so
that an insistent Starfleet scientist can't
run experiments on him which will wipe out
his memory.
The scientist argues Data, as a machine, doesn't
have the right to resign his commission, and
Picard assumes the difficult task of proving
that Data is a sentient being with the right
to make his own choices and not be subjected
to anyone else's ownership.
Picard famously tells the presiding judge:
"Your Honor, Starfleet was founded to seek
out new life.
Well, there it sits."
Data is tragically forced to sacrifice himself
at the end of the final Next Generation film,
2002's Star Trek: Nemesis, though it's hinted
he could return in a new form.
When Picard is appointed as "arbiter of succession"
by the dying Klingon chancellor K'mpec, he
helps alter the course of the Klingon Empire.
As arbiter, Picard's job is to weigh the worth
of the two challengers, Gowron and Duras.
By the end of season four's "Reunion," K'mpec
is dead, and no new chancellor has been officially announced.
Things get even more complicated when Worf,
claiming vengeance for the death of his mate
K'Ehleyr at Duras' hands, transports over
to Duras' ship and kills him.
Picard finally announces Gowron as the rightful
chancellor.
But two Klingon sisters from the House of
Duras appear with a boy named Toral, who they
claim is the son of Duras and should therefore
be considered a challenger in the rite.
Picard later confirms Toral is the son of
Duras, but that he is too young and inexperienced
to be considered chancellor.
The decision pushes the Klingon Empire into
open civil war.
Eventually, the House of Duras' conspiracy
with the Romulans is exposed, and Gowron presides
over a reunited empire.
As an added benefit, Worf and his house are
redeemed in the eyes of his people.
In spite of their respective series being
separated by two decades, Jean-Luc Picard
proves to be an important figure in the life
of Spock.
The first time Picard significantly touches
Spock's life is in the third season's "Sarek."
Spock himself doesn't appear, but his father
Sarek boards the Enterprise to negotiate a
trade deal with the Legarans.
Unfortunately, it soon becomes clear that
Sarek suffers from a rare degenerative disorder
that causes his emotions to run wild.
Picard agrees to a mind meld, so that Sarek
can maintain enough control to continue with
the negotiations.
"My mind to your mind."
In the two-part "Unification," Picard comes
face-to-face with Spock himself.
He's sent to Romulus to find Spock because
Starfleet fears the Vulcan may have defected
to their rivals.
Instead, Picard learns Spock is involved in
secret negotiations with the hopes of bringing
the Vulcan and Romulan people back together.
By the end of the two-parter, Sarek finally
succumbs to his illness, and "Unification"
ends with a compassionate and tender gesture
on Picard's part.
He allows Spock to mind meld with him, so
that Spock may connect with the parts of his
father that Picard had experienced.
Of all the Star Trek series of the past six
decades, none can boast as inventive or satisfying
a finale as "All Good Things…," the final
episode of The Next Generation.
Q causes Picard to jump both backwards and
forwards in time, so that the story takes
place in the present, past, and decades in
the future, where Picard is an older man suffering
from a degenerative mental disease.
Picard's trips to the future are particularly
difficult.
With future versions of Beverly Crusher, Data,
and Geordi La Forge all aware of his condition,
it makes it that much more challenging to
convince anyone in that time that he actually
is experiencing what he says he's experiencing.
"Yes, yes, I know what you're thinking.
It's the Irumodic Syndrome.
He's beginning to lose his mind, the old man.
Well, it's not that.
And I'm not daydreaming either."
None of the TNG movies hinted towards the
illness beginning to emerge, and the future
of the episode was only one possible timeline.
When the Next Generation crew gets on the
big screen for the first time in 1994's Star
Trek: Generations, it sadly comes with the
death of William Shatner's Captain Kirk.
And unfortunately, Jean-Luc Picard suffers
some much more personal losses, both in the
beginning and at the end of the game-changing
film.
Early in Generations, the Enterprise's empathic
counselor Deanna Troi senses something is
terribly wrong, and when she finds Captain
Picard flipping through a photo album, Jean-Luc
reveals he's just received news that his brother
Robert and his son have been killed in a fire.
The usually stoic Picard laments the loss
of his beloved nephew and reflects that without
a wife or children of his own, he'll be the
last one in his family line.
"I've come to feel that Rene was as close
as I would get to having a child of my own."
By the end of the movie, Picard loses the
Enterprise itself.
The ship barely survives a battle with a Klingon
Bird of Prey run by the villainous sisters
Lursa and B'Etor.
The crew evacuates to the ship's saucer section,
which crashes on the surface of Veridian III.
Thankfully, as Picard predicts, the Enterprise-D
won't be the last ship to carry the name Enterprise.
The final big screen appearance of Jean-Luc
Picard comes with 2002's Star Trek: Nemesis.
The Enterprise is sent to Romulus to meet
the Romulan Empire's new leader, who we soon
learn has an unexpected connection to Picard.
As it turns out, Praetor Shinzon is a clone
of Jean-Luc.
The Romulans cloned the captain in hopes of
one day replacing him with their own identical
agent, but when one of the empire's many power
shifts took place, the clone was sent to a
labor colony with the enslaved people of Remus.
Shinzon lures Picard to Romulus because the
cloning process that created him is now killing
him, and his only potential cure is a complete
blood transfusion with Picard.
Ultimately, Shinzon's plans to kill Picard
and destroy the Federation are foiled, and
the clone villain dies fighting his older
counterpart.
On top of all that, Nemesis includes huge
shifts in Picard's life, including the loss
of Riker as his "number one."
We learn early in the film that Riker is finally
taking the captain's chair on the USS Titan,
and his new wife, Deanna Troi, is coming with
him.
Picard means for Data to replace Riker as
his first officer, but the android sacrifices
himself to save his friends in the final battle.
In anticipation of Star Trek: Picard, IDW
released the prequel mini-series Star Trek:
Picard — Countdown.
The story takes place six years after the
events of Nemesis and 14 years before Picard.
Picard is an admiral commanding the USS Verity.
Romulus' star is close to going supernova,
and the Romulan Empire abandons some of its
usual paranoia and secrecy for Starfleet's
help.
Unfortunately, complications arise when Picard
travels to the Romulan colony of Yuyat Beta.
The Romulans there have enslaved the native
population and neglected to tell Starfleet
because, in the words of one of the colony's
Romulan leaders:
"Evacuating them would be as ridiculous as
evacuating the rocks and trees."
When Picard refuses to relocate the Romulans
without the natives, the colony's leaders
take him and his first officer prisoner.
Countdown gives us a chance to see Raffi Musiker
— the irreverent first officer who insists
on referring to Picard as "JL" — in action
as Picard's second-in-command during the Romulan evacuation.
We also meet the Romulans Zhaban and Laris
while they're still Tal Shiar agents, and
it's revealed exactly how they eventually
come to work for and live with Picard.
After the events of "Countdown" are resolved,
Picard and Raffi prepare to scramble a massive
fleet to relocate the population of the twin
Romulan home worlds.
The fleet is assembled at the Utopia Planitia
Shipyards with a workforce of mostly android Synths.
In a shocking turn of events, however, a plot
masterminded by a Romulan splinter group orchestrates
a Synth uprising in a historical attack on
Mars.
The assault destroys the entire Romulan Rescue
Armada.
Picard does manage to get some Romulan refugees
moved to the planet Vashti.
However, the destruction of the fleet leaves
his relocation plan in tatters and results
in a ban on synthetic lifeforms.
Desperate to fulfill his promise to rescue
the Romulan people, Picard makes a plea to Starfleet.
He wants to assemble a fleet of formerly mothballed
ships and threatens to resign if they refuse.
But In a shocking twist, Starfleet command
accepts his resignation.
Haunted by his failures and unable to muster
the same kind of respect he had in his prime,
Picard leaves Starfleet behind and goes into
seclusion at his vineyard.
He relocates a number of Romulan refugees
to his home, including his Romulan friends
Laris and Zhaban.
Trekkies were surprised w hen they tuned in
to "Picard" for the first time.
Instead of the bold, commanding captain they
recalled from TNG, they saw a dreary, tired
old man.
Following his failure to save Romulus, Picard
spends more than a decade living a solitary life.
He has only infrequent visits with old friends
from his days on the Enterprise and the Stargazer.
But his quiet life in France is upended by
the arrival of a young woman named Dahj.
This visitor appears to be the offspring of
his old friend Data, and she's being hunted
by mysterious unknown forces.
"...everything inside of me says that I'm
safe with you."
As it turns out, Dahj is actually a synthetic
life form, and she may be the key to stopping
an emerging galactic threat.
Without the clout he had in his heyday, Picard
is forced to recruit a new crew.
This includes Dr. Agnes Jurati, rogue pilot
Cristóbal Rios, a young Romulan monk named
Elnor, and his old friend Raffi.
They take on a mission to unravel a conspiracy
and stop a cosmic cataclysm.
After several detours, he finally finds the
destination of Dahj's twin sister.
She's working at the Borg Reclamation Project.
There, Picard is reunited with the former
Borg drone named Hugh, who's taken it upon
himself to assist other Borg to regain their
former lives.
More than just another chance to play hero,
Picard's mission also allows him to finally
come to terms with the death of Commander
Data.
While the story in Season 1 of "Star Trek:
Picard" is kicked off by the discovery of
Data's daughter, the action is propelled by
a mystery involving the Synths and a threat
that could wipe out all life in the galaxy.
From his Romulan housekeepers, Picard learns
that the threat may involve the Zhat Vash.
To get to the bottom of the conspiracy, Picard
and the crew of Captain Rios' La Sirena must
track down the scientist Bruce Maddox.
The mission is completely unsanctioned, and
it makes Picard a rogue agent in an unlikely
role reversal.
During the mission, Picard meets Dahj's twin
sister Soji and is reunited with old friends
Will Riker and Deanna Troi for the first time
in many years.
They help get him information regarding a
planet called Coppelius.
It's there that a new race of synthetic lifeforms
is being created, which the Zhat Vash believe
poses an existential threat to the galaxy.
As the planet comes under attack from a Romulan
fleet, Picard gets assistance from Riker,
who commands a Federation fleet to stop them.
In the aftermath, Picard successfully convinces
Starfleet to lift the ban on synthetic life,
allowing Soji and others like them to live
in peace.
The end of the first season of "Picard" includes
a life-altering change in the story of the
former captain of the Enterprise.
In the aftermath of the Romulan-Federation
clash in the skies above Coppelius, Picard
finally succumbs to the apparent Irumodic
Syndrome that has long-plagued him, and he
dies surrounded by his new crew.
But on Coppelius, Picard gets a second chance
at life.
Also on Coppelius is Data's human "brother,"
Altan Soong, who has created a bio-organic
"golem" body.
With the help of Jurati, Soong is able to
transfer Picard's consciousness in this new
golem, which is given the form of Picard's
old body.
Before the transfer completes though, Picard's
mind is transferred into a simulation module
where the consciousness of Data also resides.
As Picard and Data speak, Picard's old friend
makes one final request.
"When you leave, I would be profoundly grateful
if you terminated my consciousness."
Resurrected in his new body, Picard enters
the simulation again and says a tearful goodbye
as he shuts down Data's program one final
time.
In his new body, Jean-Luc Picard still has
the form of an elderly man but is free of
his Irumodic Syndrome.
Healthy enough to live decades more, he sets
out with a renewed spirit and returns to active
Starfleet duty.
He's accepted back into the service and appointed
to the role of Chancellor of Starfleet Academy.
As Season 2 of "Picard" begins, Jean-Luc's
life has begun to settle down again, but an
old rival shows up to make trouble.
It turns out to be the not-so-immortal Q in
Season 2 of "Star Trek: Picard."
Much like he has in the past, Q arrives to
teach Picard a valuable life lesson, and he
does it by throwing Picard and his new crew
into an alternate timeline where Starfleet
is a fascist dictatorship and Picard is their
iron-fisted tyrant ruler.
"Through a mirror darkly, and here the man
who holds the glass is darker still."
In this twisted reality, the Federation is
known as the Confederation, and Picard has
defeated all of its greatest enemies.
This includes luminaries from "Star Trek"
including Klingon General Martok, Cardassian
Gul Dukat, even beheading Sarek, Director
of the Vulcan Science Academy.
Picard has to travel back in time to save
the future.
To solve the mystery of altered existence,
Picard needs the help of the Borg Queen.
He also has to come face to face with his
own history when he meets Renée Picard.
She's an ancestor of Jean-Luc's who also plays
a key role in the history of space exploration
in the 21st century.
Her mission to Europa is critical to ensuring
the Federation's future.
Season 3 of "Star Trek: Picard" was heavily
promoted as the reunion of the crew of the
Enterprise-D, and it's because of an emerging
threat from one of the Federation's most deadly foes.
After using the USS Titan to come to the rescue
of his dear friend and on-again-off-again
lover Beverly Crusher, Picard uncovers a conspiracy
to infiltrate the Federation.
The threads begin to unravel as they encounter
a mercenary pirate named Vadic.
She is one of the leaders of the conspiracy,
and the first foe Picard and his allies have
to defeat in order to bring an end to the
emerging threat.
Vadic is a rogue Changeling who spent much
of her life as a prisoner and was tortured
by Section 31 following the end of the Dominion
War.
She's bent on revenge and needs Picard's son
to achieve it.
With the help of the Titan's jaded captain
Liam Shaw and his first officer Seven of Nine,
they help keep his son safe.
But the reasons for the pursuit remain unclear.
Season 3 of "Star Trek: Picard" introduces
Jack Crusher, the son of Jean-Luc Picard and
Beverly Crusher, whose discovery forever alters
Jean-Luc Picard's life.
He is the product of a whirlwind romance following
the events of "Star Trek: Nemesis."
Dr. Crusher hid him from Picard because she
feared he might become the target of his father's
worst enemies.
To keep him a secret, Dr. Crusher cut off
all contact with Jean-Luc and the rest of
her old Enterprise shipmates.
Alongside his mother, Jack grew up on the
edges of the Federation frontier, helping
to provide aid and supplies to those in need.
But they came under attack from what would
later be revealed to be enemy Changeling agents,
and they were forced to go to Jean-Luc for
help.
Picard is heartbroken that he had been denied
the opportunity to be a father for more than
20 years.
"And you never thought, if you had told me,
it all might have been different."
Despite the years of secrecy, Picard helps
keep Dr. Crusher and Jack safe from their pursuers.
With the aid of Riker, Picard hijacks the
USS Titan to do it and exposes the Changeling plot.
Ultimately, it's revealed that Jack inherited
a part of Jean-Luc's Borg-assimilated biology.
The Changeling, Vadic, was working with the
Borg Queen to use Jack as part of a plan to
assimilate and destroy the Federation.
As Vox, Jack controls the newly created Borg
drones and almost destroys Earth.
But after Picard makes a heartfelt plea to
his son within the Borg collective unconscious,
Jack rejects the Queen and the pair thwart
her diabolical plans.